mais messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
ya pas de doute la campagne électorale
ça s'en vient à grands pas prenons un
exemple l'avortement le droit à
l'avortement place le parti conservateur
sur la défensive aujourd'hui le député
alain rey est ce le temps politique au
québec admet depuis quelques heures
avoir mal interprété les propos de son
chef andrew scheer qu'ils comptent pas
ouvrir le débat mais permettrait quand
même le dépôt de projet de loi privé par
des députés pro vie par exemple
mais écoutons ce que disait la candidate
sylvie fréchette à notre émission et
reçoit à ce moment il me dit qu'ils
voulaient pas retourner en arrière et
qu'elle n'est pas changer la loi
donc pour moi c'est un engagement qu'il
prend et je lui fais confiance sur cet
engagement
alors jusqu'où peut-on aller pour
recruter des candidats quatre députés ce
soir en studio à québec mélanie joly
ministre et député libéral bon sur
madame joly pense à à montréal alain
reyes député conservateur élu tenant
politique pour le québec première
intervention en direct de monsieur reyes
depuis hier soir merci d'être avec nous
monsieur réal fait plaisir alexandre
boulerice député néo démocrate
bonsoir monsieur boulerice xavier
barsalou duval député bloquiste bonsoir
dont le bienvenu à cette émission va pas
que parler d'avortement mais c'est un
bel exemple monsieur reyes
il ya un flou depuis hier est ce que me
est-ce que vous avez le riz les
candidates consommatrices au québec sur
cette question lors quel numéro 6 ans
n'ont aucune mal j'ai toujours parlé
avec mon coeur et en toute sincérité à
toute transparence avec l'ensemble des
candidats et candidates que j'ai
rencontrés dans le recrutement
1 pour voir leurs intérêts sans sens
politique notre position sur ce sujet
est extrêmement clair notre chef était
clair un gouvernement conservateur et
leur jeu bien qu'on se comprenne tout le
monde entende bien un gouvernement
conservateur ne rouvrira pas ce débat ne
déposera pas de projet sur le sujet des
prêts jouez sur le sujet on veut
travailler sur des enjeux qui unissent
les canadiens canadiennes
on veut pas tomber ses chicanes là en ce
moment lorsqu'on voit si nos adversaires
dans meilleur toutes les façons de ram
usa sur le terrain nous on veut pas
parlons mais regarder en avant
mais vous avez des députés pro vie en un
qui avaient déposé des projets de loi
privés c'est une mesure parlementaire
qui est possible est ce que monsieur
chine a toujours votre parti a toujours
l'intention d'accepter comme membres de
son caucus dépose des projets de loi qui
restreindrait le droit à l'avortement
monsieur madame sûr je vous répète la
position du parti elle est extrêmement
clair notre chef a été catégorique on ne
rouvrira pas ceux des bons ne déposera
pas comme gouvernement non sélection
mais ce projet de loi mais sachez non
monsieur promotion
non mais vraiment rentrer de donner la
parole aux autres c'est important parce
que vous êtes vous empruntez un corridor
très étroit parce que vos candidats
qu'on approchait ton l'impression qu'ils
pourraient pas y avoir de dépôt de
projet de loi de députés pro vie par
exemple monsieur comme un certain
monsieur vous de voir comme ça a été
fait sous le gouvernement harper oui non
monsieur le gouvernement conservateur ne
déposera pas de projet doit notre chef
dit qu'on veut pas il est libre et les
voilà donc je vaux pourquoi vie je
trouve ça spécial quand j'entends mes
confrères et qui vont parler dans
quelques instants qui ont été maîtres
sur tous les réseaux
comme quoi que j'aurais menti donc
pensez vous vraiment qu'une dit sylvie
fréchette jusque et basher une marie
josée gerets ces femmes là ne sont pas
capables de se faire leur propre opinion
pense vraiment que j'essaie de les leur
et pour essayer de les convaincre
je trouve qu nettement s'attaquait leur
intelligence et des finances allemand
est un gentil on lit fiat aura vite
notre équipe autre que moi j'aimerais
savoir c'est député d'arrière-banc
pourrait déposer des projets de loi
j'espère qu'on aura une réponse d'ici 14
minutes
madame gélis pour vous oui ben écoutez
la réalité c'est qu'il ya un revirement
spectaculaire de situation
monsieur j eudi une chose aux québécois
et aux candidates québécoise et 10 sont
contraires à ses amis anti-choix partout
à travers le pays
on se rappellera que monsieur a quand
même été soutenu par tout le mouvement
anti choix tout au long de sa campagne
au leadership a toujours été clair sur
la question qu'il était lui-même anti
choix
et justement la réalité présentement
c'est que sa position et les flous et
d'ailleurs monsieur reyes ne pas répondu
à votre question le smad i'm so la
réalité c'est que nous on s'attend à ce
qu'il y ait de l'honnêteté de l'année tu
étais intellectuels ces couacs
l'abolition du chef conservateur en
matière on vote un avortement
monsieur boulerice là-dessus mais je
trouve ça dommage déjà que l'on doive
encore en 2019 avoir un débat qui remet
en question le droit des femmes de
choisir et de disposer de leur corps ou
une pénurie on est catégorique là-dessus
et je voulais juste porter votre
attention sur les propos de monsieur
reyes parce que oui il est très clair un
gouvernement ne va pas déposer de projet
de loi qui remet en question le droit à
l'avortement
y'a jamais dit qu'il va empêcher des
députés conservateurs de déposer des
projets de loi privés et c'est l'olp
rang
parce qu'un projet doit priver goût
qu'on appelle d'initiative parlementaire
ne doit pas avoir d'impact budgétaire
sur le budget fédéral atteindre et il m
a vraiment s'attaquer aux droits des
femmes à l'accès à l'avortement n'a pas
d'impact budgétaire donc correspond à la
définition d'un projet de loi privé et
c'est là toute la nuance est ce que
monsieur cherdi depuis 2006 que monsieur
un relief ne pas dire ses candidates
quand il les a recrutés d'etreham en
tout cas merci là dessus est ce qu'on
voit dans le fond en ce moment ne sait
que le parti conservateur s'est mis dans
le trouble parce que il tenait un
discours en français puis un autre
discours en anglais pour raconter un
discours aux québécois
quand on tient un autre discours aux
canadiens puis qu'on pense qu'on sera
pas traité même année ça finit par nous
revenir lorsqu'on voit c'est qu'on a un
parti qui essaie de dire au canada
anglais nous non tous les députés
peuvent déposer un projet de loi le pour
le contre et l'avortement alors qu'au
québec on nous dit non le gouvernement
déposera foot projet de loi sur la
question de l'avortement et la réalité
c'est que là on a un député qui nous
répètent la casse est un rassemblement
pour essayer de s'en déprendre mais il
peut pas sur l'épreuve
c'est très clair que les conservateurs
il ya des gens dans ce parti là qu'ils
ont l'intention de ramener le débat sur
l'avortement puis comment le
gouvernement va voter c'est difficile à
dire si le chef et pro avortement mots
j'ai hâte de voir de le voir de voter
contre l'avortement
ça serait assez surprenant de voir ce
serait d'ailleurs quand on a déposé une
motion ce printemps dernier pour
réitérer le droit à l'avortement mais
les conservateurs du québec le projet
ceux du canada sont restés assis puis
saglik lié contre contre cette motion à
l'os à us a tapé dans tout les sens donc
pour moi ils sont pas qu'il dise à ce
niveau là je serai jusqu où on va on
peut aller pour recruter des candidats
parce que c'est aussi plus difficile de
recruter des femmes notamment parce
qu'il ya des enjeux comme cela qu'ils
sont très importants et qu'on n'a pas la
main perspective du côté prêt dans
l'ouest du pays cotées pro-vie pas même
à une campagne quand même prouvé le pro
choix ce projet culture au québec qui
trouve que monsieur chère et pas assez
clair sur sa position
non honnêtement sa peau était déçu du
tout puis quand je regarde les qualités
nos candidats et candidates et on va
parler de nos candidates dans ce cas ci
parce que plus de 40% des nouvelles
candidatures qu'on a recruté qui ont été
élus par leurs associations sont des
femmes et des femmes extrême
fort je vous répète une sylvie fréchette
maire josé guerra est une jusque et
basher une mairie claude fournier des
femmes qui ont du caractère qui ont de
l'expérience qui se lance en politique
et dans leur tête
aucune ambiguïté par rapport à cet enjeu
là le chef déclare je me suis aperçu lui
dit c'est faux ils se demandaient
comment voter le chef
notre chef a été catégorique il ya en
europe pas de projet qui va déposer son
gouvernement conservateur on ne rouvrira
pas le débat j'ai pas combien de fois ci
j'ai vu ce que monsieur cheikh n'a pas
voté sur des projets de loi députés par
déposer entre 2005 et 2011 à l'assemblée
ma chambre des communes justement pour
des projets qui restreignait
l'avortement
monsieur scheer s'en va en campagne
électorale de mes premiers scans à 2 il
a clarifié pour être certain qu'il n'y
ait aucune ambiguïté je vous répète à
titre de lieutenant politique
un gouvernement conservateur ne déposera
pas de projet ne rouvre pas ce débat là
donc j'ai dit je peux également dit
qu'il allait permettre non seulement le
dépôt de la part de ses députés de deux
projets de loi sur la question pour
restreindre le droit à l'avortement mais
également qu'il allait faire en sorte de
permettre le vote libre à la chambre des
communes
et donc ces contrats ce que vous dites
monsieur loyal et c'est contre ce que
vous avez dit à vos candidates parce que
celle ci
l'intérêt alors qu'il vous a dit oui
madame je lis je laissais monsieur
barsalou parler parce qu'on veut savoir
se mesurer est écoutée sais pas ce que
ça tient pas la route là quand on a
quelqu'un qui dit qui est pour
l'avortement mais qui déposera un projet
de loi sur l'avortement son gouvernement
mais ses députés d'arrière-ban peut le
faire
comment ce qu'il va faire lui pour voter
contre il va voter pour cesser sa vision
personnelle puis jeudi son parti va
suivre monsieur bouddhisme ou et puis
moi je partage la préoccupation de
certains de mes collègues puis des gens
aussi des dix citoyens et des citoyennes
parce que il ya un réel mouvement au
sein du parti conservateur qui est
contre les droits des femmes qui est
contre l'accès à l'avortement qui est
contre le choix des femmes et jusqu'à au
printemps dernier il y avait une grande
manifestation sur la colline
parlementaire le groupe de la droite
chrétienne déjà très religieux très
conservateurs qui s'opposent au droit
des femmes à l'avortement il ya eu des
députés presque une dizaine de députés
conservateurs qui était présent à la
manifestation qui sont fait prendre en
photo qui ont pris la parole la boxe si
ces gens alors comme monsieur chez eux
dit il ouvre la porte à ce que ces gens
la dépose du projet de loi d'initiative
parlementaire ou privés puis monsieur
monsieur royal s'y est pris à ce moment
incapable de nous dire que ça arrivera
alors c'est sûr l'attaquant de
l'avortement maintenant je pense que
tout le monde dise qu'elle va dire là
dessus est ce que tous les partis pour
recruter surpris dans la main avec la
même difficulté les libéraux pour vous
autres je pense à dos tech et pipeline à
quelques pas de la corruption offrir la
corruption résolu la question de
l'avortement allait discuter avec tous
les députés parce que notre position les
personnes par exemple on a été capable
de le recruter steven guilbeault qui est
un environ du capital et reconnu les
corps en décomposition surpris lui qui
est en faveur de l'imposition d'un prix
sur le carbone qui est une position qui
est courageuse est importante mais je
vous dirais que pour avoir été très
impliqué moi-même dans le recrutement de
candidats et particulièrement le
candidat la réalité c'est qu'on parle
avec notre coeur et le but d'adhérer à
monsieur reyes en temps c'est formidable
on a des voitures ou électriques oui
mais je ne sais trop les mêmes valeurs
les tests les valeurs aussi pour voir si
on est capable de rejoindre
j'ai travaillé avec valérie renault
martin à trois rivières pour l'arthrite
et chantal pilon à rimouski un duo crise
de manière folle et les femmes ou s'il
parle d'une réalité qu'on parle trop peu
souvent à la télé mais aussi la
conciliation travail famille les
réalités qui sont fondamentales et qui
sont nécessaires à tenir compte parce
qu'on recrute une personne qui voudrait
c'est ce que la réalité ne fera pas les
partis politiques canadiens quand il ya
des attentes à l'ouest comme à l'est
c'est ce que vous n'avez pas un peu vécu
seul alors de lire la campagne avec ce
week-end mais moi je pense que ça fait
partie du grand dialogue qu'on doit
avoir entre la nation québécoise et les
nos amis progressistes ou au canada
anglais et puis nous au québec on est
très fier du bilan qu'on a dans le
recrutement nos candidats ou candidates
évidemment c'est des gens qui ont
recours à la justice sociale et la lutte
face aux changements aux changements
climatiques en ce moment 9 64% de nos
candidats investis qui sont des femmes
28 pour cinq sont des personnes assises
et on est des personnes exceptionnelles
tout une femme à qui était journaliste à
radio-canada nimâ machouf ont d'ailleurs
à l'imagerie dans cinq ou six on
n'aurait pas que sophie thibault qui
viennent projet montréal
alors on a vraiment des gens bien
implantée dans leur milieu qui
représentait valeur du npd de npd de
2015 avec jack médecine comme chef et
pour vous monsieur marcel ou d'un côté
c'est ce que le travail effectivement
nos candidats la puce sont pas mal tous
des indépendantistes puis je pense que
c'est une règle de base pour pouvoir
être candidat d'un autre côté vu que
c'est parmi les options qu'on défend
mais ce qui était facile de ce qui est
évident aussi c'est non bloc québécois
on n'a pas besoin de code compromettre
notre discours ou d'essayer de faire un
discours différent au canada anglais qu
un dico que disco contient au québec
qu'on parle en anglais ou qu'on parle en
français on a toujours le même discours
c'est clair que quand qu'on va voir des
gens puis que les gens savent que les
positions contient ces dispositions qui
sont sincères qui sont toujours les
mêmes
ben c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
établir une confiance au bar le
recrutement avait quand même communiqué
bec
jeudi qu'israël y est la position du
bloc québécois programme du bloc
québécois
je pense que maintenant c'est très clair
vieille histoire l'a fait ce que faisait
pas tout ça défie des durées avec la
population je veux parler de sondage
canadien tout à l'heure avec notamment
jean marc l'egypte un chercheur de
colombie britannique
les canadiens se disent méfiants face
aux politiciens qu'on considère que vous
que vous occupez pas assez d'eux un mot
là-dessus en terminant chaque heure et
chacun 10 secondes mais vous savez c'est
un défi oui en effet on doit aller sur
le terrain renouveler la confiance je
pense que partout à travers le monde
présentement les décors les démocraties
sont des défis et nous notre rôle comme
policier c'est d'expliquer en quoi le
rôle du policier a un impact dans la vie
des gens positifs et c'est pour ça qu'on
va arriver avec des bonnes idées va
pouvoir changer la vie des gens alors
déchiré yes
visuellement cette histoire là non ce
qui était facile dans notre recrutement
c'était parler des libéraux de la
corruption du problème qu'on a vu au
canada
je peux vous dire que seuls les gens qui
ont des sites se lancer avec nos
laventure sont fiers de vouloir me
remettre de l'ordre dans les finances
publiques
remettre de la transparence du
gouvernement à leur opération sera votre
peau comme d'alcool des bons à 6 qui
était passé une femme dans la
circonscription de bimi à la dalle
parce qu'elle n'est pas ramasser assez
d'argent quand on sait exactement que
s'est passé quand même sur charbonneau
donc je pense que quand j'écoute madame
joly mais il n'a de leçons 0 on va
passer l'accord merci monsieur voulait
tellement de respecter la haine
oui je pense que ce que les gens veulent
c'est des gens qui parlent vrai qu'ils
sont sincères qui disent vraiment qu'est
ce qu'ils ont dans le coeur puis dans
les tripes c'est ce qu'on recrute comme
gens comme néo démocrates nous entourent
npd qui veulent avoir des gens qui vont
aussi dû faire les bonnes choses et pas
dire quelque chose et ensuite de soi
aller acheter un ipad qui compte bien
contradictoire monsieur bah oui ben moi
je tiens à dire que effectivement quand
on parlait de corruption il y en a eu
les libéraux il y en a chez les
conservateurs jeu qu'on se moque c'est
exclusivement le dock d'anciens dans ce
parti là qui a eu donc je pourrais faire
attention à ça et pour ce qui est du
recrutement de candidats
je vous dirais que nous c'est simple on
veut on va voir les gens disant qu'on
veut des femmes du québec ont vu que
leurs voix soient tenus à prise en
compte et je pense que ça c'est
important pour eux
à l'inversé nous monsieur blairisme sur
yes man amélie merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous bonne campagne recruter de
bons candidats
et on nous dit rien on vous demande la
sincérité la vérité